our sean o'shea has been in the midst of
that police operation again today so
sean how are things looking from your
vantage point
well jeff take a look right now what
we're seeing so right behind me is an
ottawa police car we've got the opp the
ottawa police and we've got concrete
barricades and fences and these have
gone up all through the day basically
ringing this center of the city
including parliament the shadow laurier
hotel getting in to the core of the city
is not easy there are 100 checkpoints in
and around ottawa police are asking
people with their purposes to come in
here and that's because they are still
in the midst of trying to clean up this
protest trying to get rid of those
trucks either by towing them away or by
asking the drivers to drive them away
police out in full force again here
today as you were hearing and this
operation is continuing through the day
we're probably going to see this go on
for a day or two or more from now jeff
right and i understand earlier in the
day sean you were speaking with some of
the remaining protesters what are you
hearing from them today
jeff there was a sense of you know it's
coming to an end but many came up to us
to talk about what they hoped people
would remember from this protest that
they weren't all bad guys even though a
lot of people in the city here don't
lament the fact that they're leaving
here's what a couple told us
we are hard working canadians we pay
taxes
like why can't we have open dialogue you
be the light yes be the light tell us
i'm gonna watch i'm gonna watch
you tell them that there are people here
who are here for the right reasons to
fix canada
when he said we're going to watch he was
talking about watching our broadcast
watching our story because
most of these protesters came up to us
and said you're not telling the truth we
said hey watch the stories and then
judge us jeff
all right our truth teller shawn o'shea
in ottawa tonight thanks sean